emergency evacuation announcement you
have you know members attending none
minutes the meeting of the 9th of
October 2009 clear outside was an
accurate record any declarations of
interest nights and it's not normally on
this particular gender but will be from
now these questions on notice from
counselors that you can say we've had
nine but just so everybody's aware you
can say the way I would sort of change
the room a little bit had there been
anybody then they would have been
sitting at the end they're asking their
questions okay matters referred to the
executive reports from other committees
right first of all called to new 2019-20
financial management plan performance
report finance thank you
I'm not going to say a lot but that
doesn't mustn't undermined the amount of
work that goes into producing these
figures and the hard work that goes into
administering the budget on a on a daily
basis but if I can straight away take
you please to take two at seven point
two and the figure on the bottom right
of the first table which is projected
variance surplus of 491 348 pounds
[Applause]
I think that represents an excellent
performance in hard times one of the
savings have come across through stuff
savings and it should be noted that this
staff of have covered some vacancies and
problem ground to do that the various
urban areas were a DS area so they're
listed above that but and the bottom
line is it's it's hard work by the
council it's efficient management of our
finances and it's a figure that perhaps
will give us a little bit of flexibility
as we go through the rest of the year
for some initiatives that can benefit
our residents for the detail on yeah
I'll just a few more words but probably
noticed in the minutes just wanted to
note and there is an error in terms of
the portfolio holder and that's listed
for an enterprise on page seven point
ten where it's the second equally
hugglemas counselor wishing so I just
like to apologize that that was just in
human error and obviously migration
future import so yeah absent council
Smith has said we're in a relatively
healthy position going into quarter two
so the the protection under spend of
about half million pounds represents
about 5% of the revised revenue budget
so as counselors mister gives us a
little bit flexibility in terms of as
the rest of the year hopefully and the
decision has improved by about 300,000
pounds since quarter one and the main
reasons for that of an increase in the
projected salary budgets which is mainly
due to
you at the more senior post which we
were anticipating could be filled before
the end of this financial year but
currently we invest starting to recruit
to a couple of posts or we made this
sort of strategic decision that we're
going to hold off on recruitment so yeah
about half of the underspend is due to
the starting and the other key areas
that have improved our car parking
income which is the instead increased by
about fifty thousand pounds and that's
just due to higher volumes of people
using the car parks and that seat our
doing appendix form of the report
there's also a 50,000 pounds improvement
in planning in common that small cast as
50,000 pounds improvement in council tax
share back in Cumberland from our
agreement with the preceptor so there
that make they're the key variances that
have changed since last last quarter and
obviously the detail is sets out in
Appendix 1 so if anyone's got any
specific questions then I'm happy to
answer those I would just say on the
capital program as well that we are
forecasting just then by year-end about
2.4 million against a revised budget of
3.3 million there is a couple of areas
where the key areas where we're not
projecting to spend from budget one of
which we've discussed previously which
is the play spaces budget where we've
agreed to slip some of the works in
speech years and secondly the pavilions
program where we are still planning to
carry out the works but it's just
thinking slightly longer than we
originally anticipated so that will
probably slip into next year so they're
the two major sort of variances on the
capital program and so I wasn't probably
gonna say any more than that but as a
cycle is going
can I just echo what the portfolio
holder said and thank you and your thing
for the hard work I know is that going
to do this and it's a homecoming so
thank you very much for that and any
questions guys just just one small thing
I meant to mention this earlier on seven
point seven in the comment section we've
got a number of personnel named and I
don't think that's really good practice
on and generally speaking we have taken
out all night a night that I are I have
to admit that ours just slip through the
neck so and yeah the first is to the
quarter to 2019-20
revenue budget capital position settled
in Section three pennies is that noted
and one point two should note the latest
position the council's peak performance
indicators show in opinions by thank you
involved so tell me is it possible I can
just go back on something because I
think there's something that got missed
this was in the minutes sorry about this
is it there was a correction that needed
to go into the minutes
was that correction putting two minutes
from last time the correction okay well
the correction was in reference to the
sale of the land to the growth there was
a change that certain things were
emitted before those minutes which I
spoke to Sonia about
there was an omission in the minutes
we had an agreed formula for that to go
into those minutes and was that before
the minutes were published that was
before this was immediately when the
minutes were published and make it may
went out yeah I I refer that back to
Sonia and said there is an error here
that needs to be corrected she agreed on
that correction okay well I think we've
gotten to the stage that has been done
because we have agreed minute yes yes he
would be wrong I hope you sir asked you
I haven't seen the agreed minister I
haven't seen the new minute so I've seen
the old minutes but not the new ones I
haven't got them okay all right well
we'll pick up out was if there is a
still an issue they won't have to be
there at the next meeting
the original minutes that were sent out
he draft but I haven't got the new
minutes if they were Nunez it would be
rough for me to go back we have not
really no absolutely okay
okay item I paint working group some
thank you chairman and the paper before
you sets out a proposal to set up a car
park
review member working group together
with the terms of reference that that
will cover and car parking around the
district recognizes the importance and
strategic role which car parking has is
a district to support the local economy
managing traffic supporting businesses
residents and visitors the purpose of
the review is to ensure the Rockford
remains at the forefront to optimize
both usage of space and a review of
payment systems are made available for
the ease of users that's a general
summary I will be an additional
recommendation to the meeting tonight
over the Chairman you want me to do that
in the I yes if you windless right okay
a third recommendation or sorry an
additional recommendation which will be
numbered 1.3 will be added proposal that
the work of the car park review member
working group will not commence until
after the general election to be held on
the 12th of December 2019 and at that
point I will hand over to the assistant
director assets and commercial to give
any further detail he wishes just just
to clarify this because their
traditional recommendation because of
the situation Thank You Man I can't
imagine chairman and evening members and
yeah just out and see what the portfolio
holder said really and it's a pretty
straightforward report I think it speaks
for itself just to say that I support
hold assets out the council car parts
they aren't they are by class they do
provide crucial car parking vision
businesses residents and visitors to the
district and we do recognize important
role they play a strategic and an
important role in the district as the
portfolio holds has said
they do support the local economy they
do help the most traffic and do offer a
key service to residents and businesses
so it's a bat in mind that with
considers our approach to the future the
car parking and service and it is
important we do have a clear place based
strategy that we develop a stake it for
the use of systematic approach and make
sure it's evidence driven to ensure that
we can understand and address the needs
of the service now and moving forward as
a town continues to grow and indeed the
district continues to grow and develop
so it is recommended as a cross-party
member work group you establish be
established its purpose would be to
provide a forum for stakeholder input
and feedback to support the development
of that car parking strategy and an
action planning district I've appended a
draft terms of reference to the report
and stays quite straightforward but
happy to take any questions which
committee chairman yes I believe would
come to the executive committee talked
to the victim thank you just a Clarion
yeah thank you
one of the things with regard to the
draft of the member working with the
terms of reference changing I would like
that toughened up a little bit in
regards to the simple fact of if it's
across party I feel is very very
important that before any work comes to
the executive because it may be
sensitive it somewhere are I believe
there should be some provision in there
that no information from that working
group should be released in any way
shape or form before it is actually
passed and made public to the executive
and whatever form you need that being I
feel that that should be a very very
important part of any working group so
that they're able to talk freely to in
if there's any sensitive items
sensitive items that they need to
discuss none of those will be revealed
by any member until such times under the
express permission of end of the
Chairman or the executive when it comes
to publishing so at no time should any
report have any publicity by anybody
probably to actually being sanctioned by
the executive I do find that is that as
possible could the committee working
party work PLC rules even though it's
taking evidence from non-members the
information they provide to the group
would be information that a stake Allah
provides so by definition they would
that would be a motion they bring any
way in terms of confidentiality we we
could think is there a clause in terms
of whatever discussed at that meeting
and recommendations have to be remained
commercial to the report is published I
would like to take that away but I
believe we could add PFC yeah I want to
take some voice on exactly the mechanism
for that I think needs some sympathy for
councillor Ward has said I think when
you see word barking review there are
some cynical people some members some
members of our wider community who might
think that is a way of flagging up a
charging increasing car park and got
just wondered if as leader you might but
I could be categorical about the purpose
of this yet the the purpose is to look
at the provision we provide for
in terms of car parking in terms the use
of the camera the standing of the car
park
the way the car park works the mechanism
with which we do charge but not the
charge in any form of charge
increase it is purely the mechanism on
how the car pulse provides the service
thank you that's nice and clear and I
hope it will stop some mischief making
him well thank you very much maybe just
adding to that maybe there's also the
point of looking to increase spacing
because we have this issue ongoing issue
within brain especially where we're now
actually now becoming quite short spaces
and I think it's important within the
review that within that review to
looking at how we can increase the
spices we have for example with the car
park and store here at market the way
it's laid out could be more efficient it
could be better laid out in terms of
increasing the number of parking spaces
anybody else okay well we have I think
we need to make it for recommendations I
think one is the printed on page
chairman that just with what we do go to
recommendations just to reassure you
item six on the terms of reference
specifically refers to the regulations
to the executive so that put your mind
at rest in my opening comments I did in
terms of usage point out that the
district remains at the forefront to
optimize both usage and so recognizing
that there are some car parks where
there is additional potential and to to
make them more effective in terms of
usage of space layouts and payment
systems so I think looking at what
anybody has a recommendation 1.1 the
cross-party member working for is be
appointed to provide stakeholder input
and feedback to support the development
of a car parking strategy and action
plan from these things I said what are
you happy with that point to improve a
car park review CP power working member
working group terms of reference as you
pay people and just say before we go any
further with with appropriate
recommendations if they want I was going
to come to that thank you very much
chairman adding to that the next
recommendation would be that the there
is no work this really the Matt's world
look at making the Working Party work on
a P&C basis I think that's probably the
best word I can come up with listen
buddy monster
maybe ndle I would suggest that it's
simply an issue of making
adding obligations of confidentiality
means I would suggest that in addition
to recommendation 1.2 to improve the
quality projects Thank You members aware
that the program management office or
PMO reports quarterly both to this
committee and to the investment world in
respect of the various projects that are
seized of it
the PM own its current form has been
running for almost two years now and I
review it annually as part of the latest
review we considered the extent to which
the asset program has already seized by
the investment autumn has its own
reporting structure and we decided as we
visited the the role that PMO plays in
respect of providing assurance to the
council that the projects delivered by
officers are well run and well managed
so we have made some recommendations in
this report the first of which is to say
that the the homelessness project
appears to be in a position of stability
the moment in so far as the preventative
work that has been undertaken seems to
be paying dividends unclear now in sort
of more of a benefits realization piece
rather than the actual delivery and the
implementation of that preventative
strategy so as it sets out in in
paragraph three point four on page nine
point one there's a suggestion therefore
that we can take that away from the
dashboard at the moment and therefore
reporting which is done by this as two
different cream cells and housing I'm
not continuing it in any event but it
doesn't need to be reported separately
as a project if we also reviewed the
other project which is within the scope
of this committee which is the migration
project from the council's cloud
computing as it sets out on in paragraph
three point six the only outstanding
piece of work on this project now is in
relation to the migration of the
académie software for the council's reps
and benefits service into the capita
cloud that project is being managed
tightly in conjunction with capita and
has its own end date a small amount of
work will be required to ensure that
that smoothly and to make that final
migration on to the mail server as it
says but again once that piece of work
has done that project is effectively
complete and at that point the assistant
director will be producing a completion
report and we will formally close that
project out from the from the dashboard
so that means therefore members that the
only other items that would then be on
the dashboard or the legal project which
is a silver project they wouldn't let
this stage be any other
Gold projects so the challenge we took
is to say how useful is the dashboard
continues billion what is the role and
function of PMO and we certainly looked
at it in the conjunction of any further
projects that were linked particularly
to the council's medium-term financial
strategy on delivery of any savings
which would directly impact over the
course of the next five years and we've
made some suggested improvements in
updating the terms of reference and the
primary change that we've suggested is
that a tax more closely to leadership
team that projects our triaged
effectively before they're accepted into
a process that there's a series of
gateways during which point the
leadership team reviews progress and
that then strengthens the reporting as
part of the PMO so that the dashboard is
a bit richer for it
so that's the suggestion and the
recommendation therefore is that those
those documents to be to be noted any
questions
okay moving swiftly on to the
recommendations which start online
claims 9.3 around tonight page 94 the
contents obvious be great that the
updated terms of reference you work for
a new template project document set out
in the appendix to the report we agreed
okay thank you very much David
that brings the meetings